اكد الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي انه لا ينحاز
ضد احد من ابناء مصر مشددا على ضروره
تحقيق الاستقرار السياسي والاقتصادي جاء
ذلك بعد يوم من الاصداره اعلانا دستوريا
تباينت ردود الفعل
[موسيقى]
بشانه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل نجح خطاب الرئيس مرسي في تخفيف
الانقسام الذي يشهده شارع المصري وكيف
يمكن قراءه مستقبل الفتره المقبله في ظل
تباين المواقف بين القوى
[موسيقى]
السياسيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله دافع الرئيس
المصري محمد مرسي عن قراراته بتعيين
النائب العام الجديد وتحصين لجنه صياغه
الدستور ومجلس الشورى من الحل وقال مرسي
في كلمه امام الاف من مؤيديه في القاهره
انه يعمل من اجل استقرار مصر الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي وترسيخ الديمقراطيه والحريه
ومبدا تداول
السلطه يا ابناء
مصر
ما تحبون
جميعا ان يحدث ارعى
الخطوات التي تؤدي الى ما تحبون ان
يحدث
الاستقرار والاعتماد بعد الله على النفس
والوطن
الاستقرار
السياسي
الاستقرار اجتماعي
والمجتمعي
الاستقرار الاقتصادي
والانتاجي تداول
السلطه هذا ما اريده واعمل من
اجله كما تعهد مرسي بتحقيق اهداف الثوره
وعدم السماح لما سماه المال الفاسد بتخريب
البلاد واتهم قله بالاحتماء بمظله القضاء
والمؤسسات لل ضد ثوره الشعب المصري قائلا
انه لهم بالمرصاد
المال الفاسد اللي اتجمع من العصر
المجرم
يستخدم لكي يؤجر وانتم سمعتوا التحقيقات
من بعض الولاد الصغيرين اللي بيقول انا
اخدت كذا وكذا فلوس علشان احدف طوب في
شارع محمد محمود او في شارع القصر العيني
او او الى اخره
الان الثوره ماضيه ولن تقف والقانون ماض
والقضاء
مؤسسه لها قدرها
واحترامها
برجالها المخلصين لها اما من يريد ان
يختبئ داخل
المؤسسه فاني له بالمرصاد
ولمناقشة
في من خلال خطاب
اليوم مساء الخير استاذ عبد الصامط للاسف
الشديد لم ينجح الرئيس محمد مرسي يعني رغم
كل نواياها التي اثق انها طيبه لكن هذه
الطمانينه لم تصل والدليل على ذلك ان
الهتافات ما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه قبل
دقائق كنت اتيا من التحرير الهتافات تدوي
ضد محمد مرسي وضد قراراته حتى امس حتى عصر
امس كان الشارع المصري يعني منقسما الى حد
ما بشان محمد مرسي كان البعض يطالبه
باقاله النائب العام وبعاده محاكمه قتله
الثوار ولو كان محمد مرسي اتخذ هذين
القرارين اتصور انه كان سيتحول ل عبد
الناصر الجديد كان الجميع سيهتم باسمه
وكان الجميع سيرحب به ثوارا واخوانا
وليبراليين ومدنيين المشكله ليست في الق
يعني يعني القرارات التي اصدرها محمد مرسي
بعضها كان مطلبا شعبيا لكل الثوره منها
اقاله النائب العام محاكمه الثورين
تعويضات الشهداء وهذا لا خلاف عليه ولو
اتخذ ها مرسي حتى لو كانت بطريقه مخالفه
للقانون او بطريقه خارجه عن الشرعيه
القانونيه ما كان احد اعترض من الثوار
لانهم يطالبون بها المشكله البسيطه حتى
نكون واضحين ان محمد مرسي وهو يتخذ هذه
القرارات حصن نفسه بصوره لم تحدث للويس ال
16س عر او فرعون فرعون مصر لم يحدث ان
اجتمع السلطات الثلاثه القضائيه
والتنفيذيه والش والتشريعيه مع رئيس واحد
فبالتالي النتيجه النهائيه رغم كل حسن
يعني كل النوايا الحسنه لمحمد مرسي التي
يقولها والتي قالها اليوم ان شركائه في
الثوله قد صاروا ضده تخيل انك في التحليل
النهائي ان يكون محمد البرادعي حمدين
صباحي عم منعم ابو الفتوح وهو رجل لا يشكك
احد في شرعيته طارق البشر الذي وضع
الاعلان الدستوري الاول احمد شفيق كل يعني
الثوار والفلول والمحسوبين على نظام مبارك
كلهم يتوحدون ضد هذه القرارات فالمعنى
الرئيسي الوحيد ان هناك خطا سياسي قاتلا
تم ارتكابه للاسف الشديد من خلال قرارات
الامس التي قسمت وشقت شركاء الثوره قطب
العربي كما تسمع وكما نشاهد الان في ميدان
التحرير الرئيس موسي لم يستطع لم يتمكن من
احتواء غضب مخالفيه ومعارضيه والرئيس ما
زال ينظر اليه على انه
ربما اصبح يستحو على كل السلطات وان الهدف
اكثر من تحقيق اهداف
الثوره الاستقطاب السياسي لم يكن وليد
اليوم ولم يكن وليد هذا الاعلان الدستوري
وهذه الاجراءات الاستقطاب السياسي في مصر
حدث بعد الانتهاء مباشره من ايام التحرير
ايام الثوره بعد 11 فبراير مباشره حدث
استقطاب سياسي وانقسام سياسي في مصر وهذا
الانقسام تعمق مع الوقت في الاستفتاء
الدستوري ثم في الانتخابات المجلس الشعب
وانتخابات البرم مجلس الشورى وانتخابات
الرئاسه بعد ذلك واستمر هذا الانقسام
قائما اذا الاعلان الدستوري الاخير او
الاجراءات الاخيره ليست هي السبب في
الانقسام السياسي الانقسام موجود من قبل
ذلك والذين رفضوا قرارات الرئيس مرسي
رفضوها قبل ان تصدر يعني منذ قبل ان تصدر
هذه القرارات وبمجرد ان حدثت بعض
التسريبات ان هناك قرارات ما ستصدر اليوم
يوم امس اقصد عن مؤسسه الرئاسه كان هناك
حاله رفض لهذه القرارات من هذه القوى
اليساريه ليبراليه رغم انهم لا يعرفون
ماهيه هذه القرارات هم يعني الان يتخذون
موقفا رافضا لاي قرارات تصدر عن مؤسسه
الرئاسه ولو ان الرئيس محمد مرسي اصدر فقط
قرار خاص بقاله النائب العام او باعاده
محاكمه الثوار ولو انهم هم من كتبوا
القرار بايديهم كان المتوقع انهم سيرفضون
و سيرفضون هذه القرارات لان هذا اصبح
اتحفظ على اتحفظ على مساله انهم عرضوه
عرضوه حتى قبل اتخاذ القرار لان ردود الا
الافعال الاوليه التي رصدتها
الجزيره يعني كانت تصب كلها في انهم يعني
يؤيدون قرارات تنسجم وروح اهداف الثوره
ولكن القرارات التي كما قال ضيفنا عماد
الدين حسين التي تركز كل الصلاحيات في يد
الرئيس هي التي كانت محل خلاف و وقيل انها
غير
دستوريه نعم نعم هؤلاء العقلاء طبعا قالوا
هذا الكلام الذين فرقوا مثل الاستاذ عماد
حسين الان هو يفرق بين القرارات الجيده من
وجهه نظره والقرارات التي يتحفظ عليها لكن
الاخرين كانوا يرفضون القرارات جميعا كلها
في سله واحده القرا فيما يخص مساله تحصين
القرارات هذا استثناء بالفعل ونحن نقر انه
استثناء ولكنه استثناء فرضته الضروره الان
لان القرارات الاولى الجيده من وجهه نظر
الجميع ما كان لها ان تحقق ولا ان تطبق
ولا ان تستمر لولا هذا التحصين لاننا كنا
سنجد غدا احد المحامين او احد الافراد
يذهب الى محكمه او اكثر من محكمه ويطعن
على قرار النائب العام مثلا او يمكن
للنائب العام شخصيا ان يطعن في قرار
استبعاده والاتيان بنائب عام جديد وا او
احد يطعن في في الاعلان الدستوري او يطعن
في قرارات الرئيس الاخرى وبالتالي نستمر
في حاله فوضى وحاله سيوله وحاله انفلات
هذا هو القصد من التحصين والتحصين هنا
تحصين وقتي لن يستمر كثيرا سيتوقف بمجرد
الوصول الى مجلس الشبب يعني عماد الدين
حسين سمعت ما يقول استاذ قطب العربي تحصين
القرارات هو مجرد استثناء و هذا الامر
يعني لا يمكن ان يلام عليه رئيس الجمهوريه
اذا كان هذه القرارات تتخذ في صالح الدوله
وتحقق اهداف الثوره وهذه القرارات وهذه
الصلاحيات التي تصفون بالمطلقه ستنتهي
بمجرد انتخاب مجلس شعب
جديد للاسف الشديد انا اجد نفسي مختلف مع
هذه الفكره التي يطرحها اخي وصديقي قطب
العربي لانه اذكره واذكر الجميع ان كل
الحكام الذين بداوا عودا استبداد بداوا
بحسن النوايا وبداوا بان الفتره مؤقته وان
هذه ظروف وقتيه وظروف استثنائيه وسرعان ما
تتحول الى ظروف دائمه نحن المصريين
انتخبوا محمد مرسي ب 51% لكي يكون رئيسا
عاديا يطبق القانون المصريين ساروا على
حسن مبارك واسقطه لانه كان رئيسا مستبدا
لو اننا نريد رئيسا مستبدا ما الذي جعلنا
نضحي كل هذه التضحيات ونقطع من اعمار
عامين ونتخلى ون تتوقف عجله الانتاج كان
حسني مبارك بهذه المقاييس ليكون افضل لانه
كان دكتاتورا وعرفناه نحن انتخبنا محمد
مرسي ليكون رئيسا عاديا نستطيع ان نطعن
على قراراته حتى لو كانت العداله بطيئه
لكن الرجل الرجل قال اليوم استاذ استاذ
عماد الرجل قال اليوم لا يمكن ان استخدم
هذا انقل لك ما قاله باللفظ لا يمكن ان
استخدم تشريع ضد افراد او احزاب او مسلمين
او مسيحيين لتصفيه الحسابات فهذه بضاعه
رخيصه كما قال لا يمكن ان اتعامل
بها اخي الفاضل ما قاله الرئيس مرسي جيد
لكن في التطبيق النهائيه صار
لديه سلطه تستطيع ان تعتقني بمجرد انتهاء
البرنامج لانني قلت كلاما لا يعجبه لا
استطيع ان اعترض على قرار لانني لا استطيع
ان اطعن عليه القضيه ليست في الكلمات
القضيه ان انا يعني اعرف الظروف التي دفعت
الى هذه هذه القرارات لكن نحن لم نتخذ
الشرعيه الثوريه هذه الظروف حتى يفعل
المشاهد هناك كلام كثير يتناثر ان هناك
كان هناك ظروف ربما او استعدادات ان بعض
الدوائر القضائيه ستعيد المجلس العسكري
وستعيد العمل نعم العمل بالاعلان الدستوري
السابق وستطل وستحل مجلس الشورى كانت وان
هناك يعني تمويل من الخارج ومن ال دول
عربيه ودول خالجيه يقال كثير وان محمد
مرسي بهذه القرارات قد استبق من وجهه نظر
الاخوان مؤامره محكمه من كل الاطراف وكانت
الامور ربما قد تصل الى عزله كما يردد
البعض نعم نعم هذا قيل لكن يعني مره اخرى
نحن نحن اعترضنا على حسني مبارك وعلى
المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه عندما كان
يستخدم فزاعه المؤامره الخارجيه المؤامره
الخارجيه طالما انها موجوده وطالما ان
الرئيس محمد مرسي صار رئيسا ا وم مع كل
الصلاحيات ومعه كل السلطات وهو الذي اقال
طنطاوي وهو الذي عين مدير المخابرات
العامه وهو الذي يعني وعين وزير الدفاع
الجديد كان يستطيع ان يحبط اي مؤامره
ويصالح الشعب واذ لم يكن لم تساعده
الاجهزه كان يستطيع ان يخرج الشعب يقول
هؤلاء هم الذين يعطلون الامر هؤلاء هم
الذين يتامرون على البلاد اما ان ياخذ
العاطل بالباطل واما ان يجعل هذا يعني
يعني في نهايه المطاف سيد عماد عماد الدين
في نهايه المطاف بشكل او باخر بشكل موضوعي
اذا صحت هذه الانباء هل نجح الرئيس ربما
في قطع الطريق امام هذه المؤامرات اذا
شئنا نصفها بمؤامرات
من من وجهه نظري نعم هو يظن انه قطع
الطريق عليها لكنه هو يقطع الطريق عليها
قطع الطريق على الثوره باكملها جعل كل
يعني تخيل اخي ان كل شركاء الثوره ضد محمد
مرسي هذه كارثه سياسيه انا ادعو الاخوان
المسلمين الى التفكير فقط انهم صاروا قوه
وحيده ضد كل المجت
هذه مشكله سياسيه الرئيس محمد مرسي قال
الاستقرار كيف سنحقق الاستقرار والمجتمع
من قاسم نصفين
طيب قطب العربي المساله يعني لا تتعلق فقط
بخلاف بين الرئيس ومعارضيه وانقسام في
الشارع وانما وصل الامر حتى الى توتر داخل
مؤسسه الرئاسه والا اشرح لي كيف يمكن ان
افهم ان مساعد الرئيس سمير مرقص يقدم
استقالته منصبه كمساعد للرئيس احتجاجا على
قرارات الرئيس الاخيره وكيف نفهم اذا
الحوار الذي تحدث عنه رئيس مرسي وانه اجرا
قبل اتخاذ هذه
القرارات يعني انا لم اسمع الحقيقه السؤال
الصوت يتقطع لما اسمع اعيد لك السؤال
الرئيس الرئيس مورسي قال بانه تحاور مع
كافه القوى السياسيه ونحن نتحدث الان هناك
عن حاله القطا في الشارع وعن انشقاق سياسي
وغير ذلك الاش او التوتر موجود حتى داخل
الرئاسه سمير مرقص مساعد الرئيس قدم
استقالته احتجاجا على هذه
القرارات سيد قطب
العربي على كل حال يعني هو انا لما اسمع
الحقيقه السؤال سمعت بعض الكلمات فقط من
السؤال اذا كان من الممكن اعادته او انني
اجيب مباشره فيما ما سمعت نعم اسمعك الان
طيب اذا كنت تسمعني سالتك عن تفسيرك انت
لاستقاله سمير مرقص من منصبه كمساعد
الرئيس نعم الا يؤشر ذلك على وجود توتر
حتى داخل مؤسسه الرئاسه على خلفيه هذه
القرارات يعني طبعا يعني انا انا يعني غير
سعيد طبعا باستقاله الاستاذ المهندس سمير
مرقص من موقعه كمساعد لرئيس الجمهوريه ا
لكني اعرف ان مه سمير مرقص يتعرض لضغوط
منذ فتره طويله الحقيقه للاستقاله من من
موقعه وليس فقط بسبب الاعلان الدستور ربما
جاء هذا الاعلان كالقشه التي قسمت ظهر
البعير لكن انا واثق ان يعني ان حوارات
ستجري مع المهندس سمير مرقص لاعادته ربما
مره اخرى الى موقعه فنحن طبعا ومصر بحاجه
اليه في هذا الموقع لانه يوضح التنوع
الموجود في مؤسسه الرئاسه ان يكون لدينا
مساعد رئيس قبطي لاول اول مره في تاريخ
مصر يكون لدينا مساعد رئيس من الاخوه
المسيحيين وهذا كان تعهد للرئيس مرسي في
حملاته الانتخابيه ولب ونفذ هذا التعهد
مباشره بعد انتخابه اما يعني فيما يخص
ماز الرئس استشار وانظر ردا على سؤالي
يعني يعني كيف تفسر انت هذا الامر لم
اسمع طيب سنحاول نتغلب على هذه المشكله
الفنيه ولكن بعد ناخذ هذا الفاصل ونعود
لمواصله النقاش ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا
الكرام سنعود اليكم بعد
[موسيقى]
قليل اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد
نناقش الخطاب الذي القاه الرئيس المصري
محمد مرسي اليوم واهم ما جاء فيه وان كان
سيكون له تداعيات او تاثير ايجابي او سلبي
على الساحه السياسيه في مصر ضيفنا ضيفنا
في القاهره عماد الدين حسين رئيس حيه
جريده الشروق اليوميه هناك من يتهم التيار
الليبرالي
واليساريين وكل من يعني يعارضون الرئيس
مرسي وتوجهاته بافتعال ازمات لارباك
الحياه السياسيه وارباك عمليه صياغه
الدستور تحديدا عبر الانسحابات الاخيره من
لجنه وضع الدستور وايضا من خلال تحريك
الشارع تسخين الشارع ومن خلال حملات
اعلاميه وتحريض هذا الشارع ايضا بوسائل
اعلام تنتمي او تؤيد هذا التيار وكان
الهدف حسب مؤيد الرئيس مرسي هو وضع
العراقيل امام الرئيس الاخواني بين قوسين
ما
ردك ربما يكون ذلك صحيحا بالطبع لكن الفه
النظر الى ان وظيفه المعارضه دائما هي
معارضه الرئيس لا توجد معارضه تؤيد الرئيس
وفيما يتعلق الجمعيه التاسيسيه تحديدا كان
هناك وعد قاطع للرئيس محمد مرسي باعاده
قبل اعلان النتيجه وبعدها لمجموعه من
القوى الوطنيه اعاده التوازن الى هذه
اللجنه عندما شكى التيار الليبرالي او
التيار المدني من ان التيا ان التوازن
مختل اختلالا واضحا لمصلحه قوى التيار
الاسلامي لم يحدث هذا الوعد لم يتم تحقيقه
ثار الامر بصوره عشوائيه وراينا انسحابات
كثيره جدا او يعني ليست كامله لكن لبعض
القوى المحسوبه على التيار الليبرالي
الاعلام اخشى للاسف الشديد ان نعود مره
اخرى الى اعاده انتاج عصر مبارك في مقولات
مثل ان الاعلام يشوه الحقائق هناك قاعده
بسيطه اذا كان هناك اعلام يشوه الحقائق
فينبغي ان يكون هناك اعلام مضاد يصهر
الحقيقه اذا كان هناك اعلام تجاوز وتلقى
تمويلا خارجيا او داخليا لتشويه محمد مرسي
او الاخوان عليهم ان يقدموه الى محاكمه
لكن ولكن هذا الاعلام الا يرى اي ايجابيات
ل الرئيس محمد
مرسي نعم يعني ليس مهمه يعني سنفترض ان
وسيله اعلام قررت انلا تذكر الايجابيات هل
احكمها لانها لم تذكر ايجابيات ساقول
عليها انها يعني امامكن ح ترك فقط على على
السلبيات باغراض سياسيه ما يعني هذا يساهم
في توتير الوضع العام في البلاد ويعطل
الحياه
السياسيه يا اخي الفيصل هو القانون الفيصل
في العمليه السياسيه كل كل شخص يزعم في
العمليه السياسيه في مصر وفي غير مصر انه
يعمل مصلحه وطنه هو بلده ما الذي يجعلنا
ان نقول ان تصريحات محمد مرسي هي لمصلحه
مصر وتصريحات البرادعي على سبيل المثال ضد
مصلحه مصر الذي يفصل في ذلك شيئان صندوق
الانتخابات في اثناء الانتخابات او
القانون القانون هو الفيصل الرئيسي لكن
ترديد كلمات عامه ومقولات عامه لا يمكن
قياسها صندوق انتخابات صندوق الانتخابات
الم يحتكم اليه مصريون ونتج عنه مجلس
الشعب اين هو مجلس هذا المجلس
الشعب نعم اتفق معك تماما لكن انت اخترت
انت هذه النقطه الفيصليه واحييك على هذا
السؤال محمد مرسي من البدايه قبل العمل
طبقا للشرعيه القانونيه والدستوريه لم
نلجا كلنا في مصر للاسف الشديد منذ بدايه
الثوره الى الشرعيه الثوريه والا كنا
استرحنا من البدايه لكن عندما يعني تتبع
الشرعيه القانونيه والدستوريه وتحلف وتقسم
اليمين على احترام هذه المؤسسات ثم تنقلب
عليها وتقول انها شرعيه ثوريه هنا تصبح
مشكله خصوصا انك لم تشاور القوى الرئيس هي
شركائك في الثوره وقررت ان تنفرد بالامر
وحتى عندما يعني استخدمت هذه الشرعيه
الثوريه استخدمتها لمصلحه خاصه بشخصك
بشخصك كزعيم وليست بقضايا عامه عندما اقول
مره اخرى انا ارحب ببعض القرارات التي
تتخذها محمد مرسي وكانت مطلبه رئيسيه
للسوار لكن فكره تحصين قراراته هذه
المشكله الجوهريه نعم قطب العربي الرئيس
مرسي غالبا ما يتهمه من خصومه بانه يتصرف
ليس كرئيس للمصريين كلهم وانما كرئيس
للاخوان بالتحديد هذا ما يقوله المعارضون
هل برايك اليوم كان من الصائب ان ان يتوجه
الرئيس مرسي للشعب المصري وقت هذا التوتر
في في في وقت تشهدوا فيه مصر حاله استقطاب
وانقسام من امام قصر الاتحاديه وامام
انصاره ليطمئن المعارضه ام كان عليه ان
يتوجه للشعب المصري عبر عبر التلفزيون
الرسمي
للاسف انا لم اسمع شيئا هناك مشكله في
الصوت نعود مره اخرى الى ضيفنا عماد الدين
حسين اذا كان في امكان ان يعني ان نتجاوز
هذا الخلل فني حتى نتمكن من محاوره قطب
العربي ليتنا نكمل الحلقه بضيفي وليس بضيف
واحد عماد الدين حسين انتم تطالبون الرئيس
بان يتراجع عن القرارات الاخيره ويبدو من
خلال خطاب اليوم ان انه قد لا يتحقق ذلك
ولم تكن هناك اي اشاره من الرئيس باي بانه
قد يقدم على خطوه الى الوراء اذا اصر
الرئيس على هذه القرارات ما الحل
برايكم اولا يعني احييك على السؤال السابق
للزميل القطب العربي لانه للاسف الشديد
كان ينبغي على الرئيس محمد مرسي ان يخاطب
المصريين من عبر التلفزيون الرسمي او عبر
كلمه المسجله لكن اختياره
اليوم امام انصاره فقط امام تيار الاوان
جعله للاسف الشديد ربما دون ان يقصد انه
رئيس لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين وليس رئيسا
لكل المصريين رغم انه تحدث الرجل كثيرا
انه يخاطب المصريين ولا يفرق بينهم لكن
الرساله السياسيه للاسف الشديد وصلت مشوهه
اعود الى الجزء الرئيسي والجوهري من
السؤال فاقول انه للاسف يعني القوى
المدنيه منقسمه هي تجمع على رفض هذه
القرارات لكنها حتى هذه اللحظه منقسمه
الميدان اليوم كان به عدد لا باس به من
المتظاهرين قد يعتصمون لكن مذا محمد مرسى
اليوم لم يبدا لم يعني يبدا اي بادره كي
ترادي عن القرارات او بعضها على الاقل
وكانت رسالتي واضحه انها انه ربما يدخل
اكثر في صدام لكنه ترك الباب مواربا
للحوار مفتوحا
للحوار نعم الحوار مفتوحا اتصور في
النهايه ان الذي سيحسم المساله هو مدى
قدره الشارع على تنظيم نفسه اذا استمر
الاعتصام او التظاهر بقوه خلال الفتره
المقبله فقد يقتنع الاخوان المسلمين انهم
ليس وحدهم في الميدان وان هناك قوه اخرى
كانت ذات يوم شركه لهم في الثوره نعم لكن
اكن يعني هناك الان قراءات اخرى تقول بان
الخلاف الان في مصر ليس خلاف سياسي وانما
هو خلاف ايديولوجي بالدرجه الاولى وان
هناك ازمه ثقه بين التيارين المعسكرين هل
هناك فرص حقيقيه لكي ينجح هذا الحوار الذي
يفترض ان ينطلق بين القوى السياسيه في ضوء
ما قاله الرئيس مصري اليوم وكيف يمكن ان
يتم تجاوز ازمه
الثقه اخي عبد الصمد تعلم ان خلافات كثيره
في دول كثيره هي اختلافات ايديولوجيه
شهدنا الخلاف بين المؤتمر الوطني في جنوب
افريقيا وحكومه الاقليه البيضاء وكان خلاف
وجودي ورغم ذلك تم حل عندما تم توافق
سياسي وتوافق دولي تم حل المشكله وتجاوز
المشكله وعيش الطرفان في استقرار واضح
ونهضت جنوب افريقيا فان نع عن الوصول
التوافق بين قوى سياسيه كانت ذات يوم
شريكا في الثوره الامر يتوقف على الطرفين
لا استطيع ان الوم محمد مرسي فقط لكن
اطالب طيب و اريد ان يكون هناك طرفان في
الحلقه ايضا لان الصوت عاد مره اخرى اسمح
لي استاذ عماد اسمح لي ان اشرك معي قطب
العربي في الثواني الاخيره سي قطب العربي
لتخفيف الانقسام في الشارع المصري هل
تعتقد بان الرئيس الرئيس محمد مرسي سيتخذ
خطوات ما لكي يعني يحتوي هذا الخلاف
الدائر الان
لا واضح ان هناك مشكله في الصوت حينما
يسال الاستاذ عبد الصمد سؤال يبدو تحدث
مشكله في الصوت انا لا اسمع اطلاقا السؤال
لا تسمع
اطلاق للاسف اتمنى تكون هذه الحاله الان
في مصر بين طرفي الخلاف الا يسمع احدهما
الاخر على كل حال اشكركم ضيفين عماد الدين
حسين رئيس تحرير صحيفه الشروق اليوميه من
القاهره وايضا قطب العربي القيادي في حزب
الحريه والعداله ايضا و اشكركم مشاهدين
الكرام لمتابعتكم بهذا تهي هذه الحلقه
شكرا لكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]
وبركاته